the Joe Rogan experience let me ask you
this do you think Andy Ruiz being the
heavyweight champion to bring Mexicans
and the rest of America closer together
I think so
well if he starts [ __ ] everybody up
what did he [ __ ] up everybody what if
he becomes a man that would be amazing
Viva Mako man crazy be interesting right
like what Joe Louis was or what Muhammad
Ali was during the civil rights movement
how about that what's his record has he
ever lost
I think he's 31 and won one loss but it
was a split decision to Joseph Parker
who's a legit world-class fighter hmm
I'm sorry one decision like 29 yeah he's
young young guy and he's [ __ ] good man
like he's good people get confused
because the way he looks
that [ __ ] throws hands and the
way he punches is super fluid
everything's like nasty combinations
like way quicker than most heavyweights
wait wait quicker
really interesting man when you watch
him fight like wow so the fights the
fight is him versus that bronze bomber
guy well I would imagine the fight is
the rematch in England and [ __ ]
Wembley Arena or some [ __ ] in front of a
million people that's probably him to be
the rematch and if he [ __ ] him up again
which man I don't know what happened in
that fight but fight Tyson Fury too
right oh yeah for sure yeah he could
fight Tyson Fury I mean Andy can fight
Tyson Fury and he can fight
Deontay Wilder but the big money I think
is in the rematch that's probably the
big money is and then that's the problem
with that is man all of a sudden that
heavyweight division looks good it's
cool what's great right now this is as
good as the heavyweight divisions been
in decades it's amazing right now but
the most exciting is de'aunte because
de'aunte flatlines people with one shot
in this crazy way and he's just built
like he's built like a giant Tommy
Hearns almost like you know when he just
he just got crazy power man his power
makes me just put my hand on my hand and
go what the [ __ ] you think Francis and
gun
a box I know he could box with the table
at the top level no I mean I think he
could with training but he's a little
older too you know Francis is Helen
how old is Francis I want to say he's 34
he started fairly late in life learning
how to fight in period but he's so big
and so powerful man was he
32 32 that's young let's be young he's
he in my opinion is the most dangerous
one punch guy I've ever seen he if you
make any mistake with that guy
heavyweights just go flying across the
room yeah I think up Francis and Ghana
versus Andy Ruiz would be big and URIs
is a way better boxer so he's a way way
way better boxer it's a big difference
so any any says it hundred amateur
fights people would see it just like
people want to see Floyd Mayweather vs
Conor McGregor yeah but it's kind of the
same in the same way that you know you
know Conor McGregor knocks people dead
in the UFC and you know Floyd Mayweather
is the greatest boxer of all time of all
time I mean he's probably the most
skillful defensive artist we've ever
seen and you know Floyd got hit a couple
of times
the thing about Frances and Ghana is I
think even with big gloves you can't let
him hit you like that if he gets it like
if Floyd the way Floyd got hit with that
uppercut by Conor kind of just kind of
placed it there he popped him it was a
good shot but Floyd didn't get wobbled
he didn't get dropped if Francis hits
somebody like that I don't give a [ __ ]
who you are if he hits you with that
Alistair Overeem left hook that he hit
Alistair with get the [ __ ] out of here
no one surviving that he just seems like
the way he knocked out Kane we clipped
him with that little short uppercut and
Kane seemed like he didn't even know the
hit yeah I think he hits stupid hard
like crazy ridiculous off the charts
hard I think when he hits people they're
just like what in the hell the only guy
who's been able to survive that [ __ ] is
steep bay and of course Derek Lewis but
they just didn't do much to each other
in that fight everybody else he touches
you with that [ __ ] and you just go
flying
he hits so goddamn hard that if he just
went into boxing straight and said at
UFC
who the [ __ ] knows man he could be the
[ __ ] heavyweight champion in the
world like legitimately if you stop and
think about how quickly Deontay Wilder
went from boxing to earning a bronze
medal in the Olympics it was a year and
a half
meanwhile there is exceptionally
talented exceptionally powerful
unbelievable one punch knockout power
but so is Francis like if Francis has
chosen to go that path one [ __ ] nose
man who knows